hey
wie soll ich denn mitten in der nacht
hin
verdammt es tut mir wirklich leid dass
ihr stress habt stress ich glaube es ist
vorbei
seine freundin ein kind
ich bin nicht der vater wie meinst du
dass ich kann nicht mal mit wieder auf
wenn jede nacht die sau rauslässt
wenn wir uns jetzt so sehen könnte
kennt er den fotografen eigentlich
persönlich keine ahnung
lukas meint er liebe fotografie und
stehen auf der gästeliste
das team für das shooting ist ziemlich
schnell zusammengestellt er ist eben ein
macher und gut vernetzt was eine
objektive meinung ist selbstverständlich
so sieht man sich wieder guten abend vor
allem viele frauen entschuldigung
namensgedächtnis ist wirklich eine
katastrophe
ich bin franziska noch rasantes aber
gerne dschungel darfst vorstellen
franziska dupont die fotografinnen
dieser wunderbaren werke und unseres
shootings für volkmann medium sehr
freuen
franziska wir können es doch nutzen kann
ich bin alex alexander ist wie du weißt
der eigentümer und leiter motto zusammen
alexy wenn sie richtig ich bin
beeindruckt er hatte schon einen
richtigen namen in der branche gemacht
ja so kann man das sagen wir arbeiten in
der franziska wurde uns erstens
hoffmann medien empfohlen ich bin froh
dass ich sie heute trotz dieser
anstrengenden etage unser projekt
gewinnen konnte natürlich wäre deine
werke sprechen für sich
danke ich würde mich auf jeden fall
freuen teil was prägt das zu sein
ich sehe nichts was dagegen spricht dann
besprechen wir alles weitere später
herzlich willkommen an bord franziska
das ist die mailbox von jude law gerade
nicht drangehen freue mich arbeiten
du hast wirklich großes talent franziska
du bist eine richtige kanzlerin heißt
übrigens ist schon mehrmals mein freund
von dir dass du malst ihn
ich erinnere mich dass dass es während
eines fototermins entstanden für ein
musikmagazin war meine güte wie heißt er
denn noch gleich
jost frontmann der band 16 auch richtig
so von soundso das kann selbst das
wirklich breunig sollte besser nach
hause gehen ich begleite dich hat mich
gefreut fantastische bilder wirklich
schönen abend noch
danke uns schön dass sie vorbei gekommen
sein
danke
gal von anderen habt ihr schon kringel
in hast du denn die ganze zeit
das ist franziska meine verlobte